there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock what are you there
it's episode 125 yes skinwalker ranch
this has been requested by a bunch of
different people I didn't know [ __ ]
about this honestly yeah we researched
it for a little while yeah I did most of
the research on well you even like we're
some document yeah I watch it so so you
actually kind of know something yeah I
got a good feel for the case I guess and
what we'll do is we'll just kind of go
through this you know slowly and try to
weed through it I mean it's a it's a lot
of different reports around this case
and yeah once you start seeing stuff
like this you gotta kind of separate the
wheat from the chaff yeah I mean I think
I I get the impression that you know the
most people know about it they probably
know about it mostly for the copious UFO
sightings or you know settings but
there's so much other fun [ __ ] going on
supposedly in the area there's cryptid
altar guys holder guys stack tivity
bulletproof coyotes dimensional the
portals yeah you know yeah it's just
like a vortex of paranormal rosiness
right in one little spot you gotta
approach this with an open mind and give
everything a fair shake but you have to
look at everything individually in this
case there's just so much stuff yeah
yeah crazier than others yeah as we will
see but like I said this has been
requested at least two times and so this
is kind of and this has kind of fits in
with our whole paranormal we don't do a
lot of UFO things but this you know this
is not just UFO there's a bunch of other
[ __ ] going on too so let's see before we
get into that let's do our little shout
outs at the beginning as I said faceless
villain volume to the audiobook is
finally out it went up on Christmas Eve
or Christmas Day or something like lion
off the shelf it's been selling very
well
it seems to be like selling like back
selling some of the first volume 2 which
is yes and yeah and so yeah so that's
really good so think to generate that
it's generating interest in the older
stuff to I know I'm gonna have to like
start I'm gonna try and get volume 3 out
this year in 2018 you know and hopefully
it won't take long I'll try and plan it
better from what we've been finding out
really to do a well-researched book
that's of a decent size that the market
will will want to buy you're talking
about a year that's about how long the
last one took it didn't take a year to
write it but it took how long it takes
to get to market yeah it took like six
seven months to write it and then you
know doing the audiobook cuz I had so
many technical difficulties so that took
a lot that's right you may be able to
trim a couple months off that that's
what I'm thinking because I'm trying to
get him get it right the first time cuz
we're building sound proofing here yeah
when the sound booths done and the
equipment yeah so hopefully maybe ten
months so hopefully I won't have to do
it over yeah like I did before like two
or three times cuz all the files were
[ __ ] up yeah and then other things
kind of come up but maybe we can get it
in ten months but yeah so if you haven't
bought it in if you would like to buy it
like I said when I wouldn't if I get the
codes for the free ones I'll be sending
them out to the patrons first and then
if I have any left all kind of open it
up to the general public but if you
would like to purchase one and you want
to do a sister a solid yeah then if you
do not have an audible account already
then you can go to audible and sign up
for an account and if my book is the
first one you buy and you have to use
the link so I'll put the link in the
description it has to be that
particularly otherwise it doesn't you
know otherwise I don't get it but if
that's the first book you buy after you
set it for audible then I get a bounty
75 $75 per yeah so yeah it's like that's
really cool yeah they they used to have
it like I said you know anytime somebody
signed up for audible and yours was the
first book they bought they'd give you
50 bucks automatically now they give you
more but they make it a little harder
they have you know you have to have a
specific link
yeah ask me somebody you've recruited
yeah that's pretty much what
that link is for ya and then how long do
they have to be an audible member what's
the minimum on that you know we're not
really sure I don't think I thought you
could cancel anytime that's kind of a
thing where cuz I know some things are
like oh you have to have three month
minimum or blah-dee-blah
but I think you can just pretty much oh
girl anytime I did you know I mean we
don't know that we don't know the deed
yeah I'm not really sure how but I'm
just saying if you're not already an
audible member if you are an audible
member that you can just go in there
right regular and obviously I'll get
royalties from that yeah and you get it
for free yeah get your first copy for
free I'm right they have some kind of
thing where if you sign up like you get
one book for free years yeah get it for
free but then I think I think they do
have to buy some other books I don't
know yeah I should probably like look
into that one these days sells no matter
what you know we haven't really been
focusing on recruiting for audible yeah
you know yeah maybe we should probably
look into seventy five dollars a head
but yeah so there's that whole thing
also for our last movie retrospective
but you didn't see it we actually did a
new movie Mandy with Nicolas Cage that
crazy acid trippy
kind of movie and actually we got a
really good response for that but I
think that you know from here on out
we're probably doing old ones we're
gonna try and do you know because like I
said you know we have a shutter and
shutter keeps adding they add new ones
but they add like old classics all the
time to like [ __ ] just a couple days ago
they added the changeling for heaven
sakes even though we already did a
retrospective on that I think we oughta
kind of do I think we ought to kind of
open it up and just do movies that we
find they're important so important to
recommend then we recommend them I mean
I laid we should just look at that way
yes I'd like to do tasks yeah that's
right it's like and we maybe we got to
talk about tasks that was that was a
weird flick I kind of want to see the
other ones because well the other one
because I think Kevin Smith he's doing a
trilogy I don't think he's made the
third one yet but the first one was
called yoga hosers and I think that they
have that on Netflix or they did last
time I looked so I might have to watch
that as well I don't think you have to I
don't know if this
these are connected I think it's more
like a thematic trilogy than a plot
based trilogy but that I liked the fact
that I went into it not knowing anything
about it you know I mean because I all I
knew was the title and yeah somebody
recommended it and I was just like okay
we'll watch that somebody told me this
was all right now I was watching going
what the [ __ ] come on yeah yeah it's
best if you don't know anything about it
yeah I watch one called tusks I had no
idea
yeah just try to work that one out with
yourself when you see that one you know
because I had to work that one I was
thinking about that four days after were
going but like we'd be laying there at
night he'd be like yeah but why though
like why did you have it anyway
yeah we're those eyes of what were those
the tears of a walrus man I guess it's
still on that place but yeah so like you
said I mean I like I said since it's a
retrospective I'd like to kind of stick
with older movies and like movies that
we grew up with but if we see new ones
that we really really like and want to
do a show about then yeah we'll just
kind of do the ones that are important
you know it's mostly gonna be older
movies but yeah sometimes there's new
stuff that appears that you got to
mention it yeah yeah and I think we
definitely will we can open up cuz like
we said we did Blade Runner 2014 I know
we've done like yeah um too important to
pass up we gotta you know give me a
heads up you know yeah exactly and you
know people if people want
recommendations for newer stuff that we
thought was good then that would be good
also obviously if you'd like to
financially support show you to our
patreon page and we got two new patrons
this week Rob and Richard so hey you
guys I don't know about very much yes no
good well I told you about one of them
but I think we just got the other one
like today or yes thanks guys
yeah so thank you very much we
appreciate any little help you can
channel growing channels growing we have
all these 5,000 subscribers on you guys
trying to get the patron support up to
around a thousand when that happens
about that'll be cool we're almost
halfway there about halfway there
yeah but um so I think that's probably
all of the shoutouts we had to do right
I can't think of anything else that we
had just get into this case let's talk
about the skinwalker ranch now
apparently reportedly allegedly even
before there was a homestead on this
particular piece of northeastern Utah
yeah there were Native American legends
about how this ground was cursed or
there was they call it in the path of
the skinwalker yeah that's why it's
called skinwalker ranch you know the
skinwalker is it's kind of like a Navajo
witch who like dresses up his animals
and like turns in animals like it's
essentially like a werewolf II type you
think I associate this case a lot with
art Belle because yeah this was like on
art bills coast to coast a lot that's
when I first heard about it well it's
just such a rich vein
yeah and Knapp was behind it what was
his name again John I think it was
George George Nass first name who he was
he was on there a lot talking about this
case yeah that and this other guy who
was uh like a real estate investor man
four guys named Bigelow Bigelow yeah
Bigelow was involved involved with this
too he was did bunch of contracting work
and well cuz he bought the I think he
bought the ranch yeah he's into the
paranormal say he wanted yeah what was
up he wanted to set up like a research
yeah he was into UFOs and stuff so he
said I'm kind of like a scientific
research unit there to try to figure out
what was going on at this location which
that in itself is kind of strange I mean
you have a you know I guess he's a
billionaire now he's he's at least a
millionaire yeah
this ultra rich guy who's bought a piece
of property that he thinks it's a bunch
of paranormal activity going on he sets
up a special paranormal unit to
investigate yeah pretty weird you know
makes you think something might be going
on there yeah it might because like I
said that seems to be the bulk of their
report to be about like UFO type like
interdimensional being Texas yeah and I
think Bigelow also was doing things like
making drones for the government if I
remember correct
yeah so you know I mean there's then
there's all these rumors of like alien
and human crossbred technology to make
drones and that's just how I remember it
you know I mean you know you know how
art Bell was you know they had a good
show and art Bell was a very charismatic
guy he could make even a boring subject
sound really mysterious with his new way
his voice is the way he presented things
yeah and you know our Bell didn't
believe everything that he did he cover
lines show us no no he tell you you know
later on I don't really believe that but
watching the show any one of his radio
shows that watching I mean he there was
no it was just all audio was already of
listening to his show no matter what the
topic was it was interesting yeah and
you know this is this you know
skinwalker ranch was one of those topics
you know it was on there regularly
that's that's mostly what I remember
about this although I feel like even
though the history of this place seems
to go back a long way I feel like it
didn't seem to seep into the public
consciousness until later until like
book of books started coming out about
like in the 2000 yeah Bigelow was trying
to keep the location the place secret if
I remember correctly yeah yeah I don't
know if it was mentioned if you found
that out in your research but they
everybody knows where it is now but
there was a time in which you know he
was trying to keep the location of a
secret yeah but apparently like I said
so the ute tribe which lives in that
area supposedly they had all these
stories about this place that you know
skinwalkers it was like cursed and [ __ ]
like that
um the area known as skinwalker ranch
nowadays is about 480 acres like I said
it's in northeastern Utah that's big
yeah it's yeah it's a very large piece
of land
um and it's it's near um military base
for the Duchene or however you pronounce
that it looks like it looks like do
Chesney but I'm assuming that it's
probably do shame because that's like
French yeah but yeah so like I said they
apparently skinwalkers had been seen in
this area like a long time ago looking
like men with dog heads or like look
smoking cigarettes for whatever reason
or like big ass where will
looking people with red eyes based on
the size of it that would be a good
facility to build things like drones and
secret yeah for the government it looks
like it's kind of out in the middle of
nowhere I mean I've never been to Utah
so who knows who knows if Bigelow bought
this you know and that was just a cover
story that he gave to you know I'm
buying yeah to research the paranormal
maybe I've been maybe there's just a
secret facility where you can make
drones out maybe he's a supervillain
anyway but um alright so apparently the
first kind of rumblings that something
was weird about the place according to
the website for this first Ken Walker
ranch skin watch a skinwalker ranch
network or whatever it is first kind of
came about now the first time that
homestead was built on it was apparently
in 1905 and this was the Myers family
I'm not sure if they cuz apparently this
particular family lived there until like
1987 right so they either moved into it
in 1905 or sometime in the 1930s I kind
of got differing sources on that but
they did apparently live there they
built a homestead there and the family
like lived there for decades and decades
now these people that lived here
apparently never reported anything weird
from either 1905 or 1930s up until 1987
but other people in the area did like
other ranchers and you know other people
in the neighborhood because some of the
even some of the ute tribes around there
said well it's not so much the
skinwalkers like on that particular
piece of land it's Lee usually like on
the ridge that's like right above there
which they called skinwalker Ridge or
werewolf Ridge or whatever it is that
it's called so this Myers family has
been living here but apparently from
around 1906 to 1911 people who lived
around the area reported stuff like
explosions that they weren't really sure
where they were coming from like
underground rumbling type noises like
earthquake II type activity that kind of
stuff that they never could determine
where exactly it was coming from or what
exactly was
causing it and that seems like that was
pretty much the main thing before then
there wasn't any mines in the area oh I
don't know there it's it seems kind of
likely that it was it's interesting that
they mentioned this is like an unusual
thing because that seems like there
could be a really reasonable right
especially way out there in the [ __ ]
desert looking for gold and stuff in the
early nineteen hundred's ago yeah so
then around the 1950s and 1960s this is
when you start seeing like an upswing in
UFO reports not so much on the ranch
itself but in the surrounding area so
you know people are seeing stuff that
looks like I mean the the reports are
apparently like all over the map
fireballs aircraft that looked like 20
to 30 feet across aircraft that are as
big as a football field some of them
were round some of them were cigar
shaped or saucer shaped some of them
were ovals some of them were triangles
some of them had red light some of had
green lights so the kind of the yeah the
descriptions of it were just all over
the place but apparently there were a
lot of them in the in the decades
between the 1950s and 1960s and now the
source of these is just one this is what
is all over the place that was other
researchers have said that they found
out that these reports have happened
yeah and I found a couple old ones in
like old newspapers from around then
from in that area okay so what that
means is that you're not talking about a
situation where modern researchers are
just saying well now they're ass oh yeah
they've been seeing UFOs here for a
hundred years so there actually were UFO
reports in the newspaper there were a
couple small ones Hioki so evidently by
the time the 1970s rolled around the
highway patrol they were saying like
well we are not even coming out there
for the reports anymore just because
there's so many and you know we never
find anything when we come out there so
we're just assuming that it's either
people making it up or it's something
that's you know completely mundane and
we don't even want to bother and that's
honest about ghost lights it's always
kind of what you know is I don't think
it's ever been
you know really properly explained
famous that one famous said I can't
remember where it's at but there was one
very famous that there were supposedly
ghost lights and stuff and I think they
did determine later on that it was
headlights but seen like in a really
strange way like the way the land was
like made it made them reflect weirdly
okay like on the mountains or whatever
so you could see them like in a place
where you wouldn't normally yeah there
was there was if it was flat I saw one
show where there actually sat out there
and just looked at him and they could
see him yeah and you know there was a
there wasn't any roads out there there
was like a little small Hills yeah you
know when they approached them they
vanished but it was a mirage like
phenomenon they didn't know where it was
coming from yeah weird this type of
stuff like ghost light type stuff where
you're just seeing lights in the
distance like that I mean there's so
many things that could be I mean it
could be like weird atmospheric
phenomenon it could be fireflies it
could be well you know what depending on
where courts may be like courts under a
lot of pressure and Ethier this yeah
that dear courts like yeah yeah and
actually some of the stuff that I was
reading about skinwalker ranch had said
that geologic it's possible that there
could be geological pressure that's
causing a couple of the things like a
couple of the weird light sightings and
stuff like that now in 1978 and this was
one where I found actually quite a big
article from the 1978 August 1978
Deseret News Online which I found the
original article now apparently there
was a mass UFO sighting in August of
1978 this was about ten miles away from
the ranch though so the first person to
report seeing it was a 13 year old boy
and his name was Dale wood and he was I
guess him and his family like all that
kind of lived in this big sprawling
trailer park or something like that so
he was walking from his house to his
grandmother's trailer and he said while
he was walking was about 10:30 p.m. on
August 11th he's walking to his
grandmother's trailer and he sees this
big
silver dome shaped object that had
intense green lights coming out of it
that were jagged he said it was like
flames kinda like it was coming out of
it
now he said that while it was kind of
over there he could hear like a softly
purring engine but then it kind of went
right over his head and he said he'd
then he couldn't hear it anymore now he
said when he looked up and so and looked
up at the bottom of it he could see the
bottom he could see the intense green
lady said the the light in the middle
was way more intense than it was around
the edges and it was like a bright
bright green
it was dome shaped yeah he said also he
told the newspaper that he got the
distinct feeling that it was watching
him mm-hmm
so he said it starts circling so his
aunt's house was like right there pursue
he ran over there and he called his mom
who was at his grandmother's house which
is where he had been walking to now his
mom was obviously like knock it off kid
I don't believe you but then apparently
a bunch of appliances at the
grandparents house like the air
conditioner and all the TVs and stuff
like all shut off at once okay which
they thought was very weird they also
reported that the dogs were acting
really weird like whining and barking
and looking at nothing and stuff well he
saw it what happened to it well that's
what they're working gets out and the
mom comes outside of the trailer and
then she said she saw it too okay the
same thing she described it the same way
and then they said well then we got the
impression that it kind of went over
there and landed someplace and then we
heard they said we heard far away like
the sound of like a herd of horses
running like they were afraid of
something and they were like getting the
[ __ ] out of there hmm so at this point
the mom calls the police department
which was the ute Indian tribe police
department who was that was their
jurisdiction they sent an officer out
his name was David Murray he comes out
to the site and he also told the
newspaper that he saw the exact same
thing he said it's a silver dome shape
thing with green lights coming out of it
when they first reported it they found
out later on that there was this other
woman she was a reporter and her name
was mrs. Rasmussen and she was driving
along a road like right nearby with her
ten-year-old grandson in the car and she
said hey we saw that thing too it's like
we saw it over the car and
we pulled over on the side of the road
and got out to look at it and so she
said it you know went over the car and
then it flew off to the north like kind
of went behind the mountains so there
are several sets of witnesses yeah
that all said they saw pretty much the
same thing just a dome-shaped object
with a green bright light in the center
of it yeah like little flame green he
said they looked like flames he said
they were jagged like flames dude I
guess that was the impression I got and
he said it was large but he didn't
specify like how large you know what I
mean I'm like are we talking about the
size of a bus large we drive like a
football field large what kind of larger
we talking about right but he didn't
really say and then it landed yeah so
that might be even a balloon you know
yeah they said they got the impression
at night though right it was yeah it was
about 10:30 11:00 at night yeah it
wouldn't be a balloon maybe one of those
Chinese lanterns yeah but that's B yeah
you know because they saw a UFO looking
yeah they're some of them yeah you can
make a Chinese lantern look really UFO
looking you make I saw one look just
like an owl when I was in Brazil we've
that yeah it was made it look just like
a perfect image of an owl sitting on a
branch it was it was to symbolize a
school that's amazing yeah look good I
keep telling him like man if we had the
resources and you know stuff we could do
like one of those later yeah just kind
of release it and then just see if
there's UFO reports have you thought
about what's we've thought about you all
that's what we've ruined it now yeah
nothing but just colored like crepe
paper and little candles or crepe paper
wrapped around little sterno cans yeah
and they're all tied together and
they're all on little balsa wood rods to
fix them all that it's so if the image
itself is what is one mass of small one
foot in diameter crepe paper hot-air
balloons and yeah light up and whatever
color you make the balloon out of that's
kind of like a pixel in the picture yeah
and you kind of make a it's a 2d statue
that look like a damn al sitting on a on
a branch it takes a bunch of people to
launch it you know yeah you got a light
light them as they go and then you know
and it starts to get lie
lighter takes a bunch of people and then
eventually you got the thing where it's
got enough force to start pulling itself
up and then you're lighting them on the
bottom and you got I mean each level
you're lighting it as it goes and then
it takes off yeah pretty cool one that
was just round or you know was just
oval-shaped I mean if you didn't know
what that was
yeah you would for real think it was
easy if I would think was a UFO because
that's not the first thing that your
mind jumps to they don't really have
those a lot here I guess you know what I
mean because you saw them mostly in
Brazil there was one you know the big
UFO from Close Encounters the one look
at the big UFO city yeah they made one
that looked like that it was just a
bunch of balsa wood like foam in that
shape yeah and look like a big flying
but you know the size of the things that
are canta and then Brazilians will know
you know if anybody resilience are out
there you can confirm this you know in
the comments section
Brazilians can make those little those
little Chinese lanterns look like
anything if you gotta have Brazilians in
enough paper no balsa wood you can does
it chip in to make it and yeah fantastic
yeah unbelievable you see it you know
what I'm saying they were deceptive you
can't really tell how big they are yeah
you know it might only be about 30 or 40
foot in diameter that in distance but at
a distance it looks even bigger than
that which is crazy because you don't
have a sense of scale right yeah you
just see like a thing like float yeah
and you're not sure how far away it is
or how high it is but it'll be bright
and you're like that thing must be you
know the size of an arena you're like
now it's more like about 40 feet in
diameter but it looks huge for some
reason huh because you can't tell how
far away it is I want to see you pride
him on YouTube yeah okay so after this
other report of it then there's this guy
his name is jr. Hicks says his name is
actually James X but he's known as jr.
he's a science teacher but he is also a
UFO investigator in the area so he comes
out to check out what's going on now
during the course of his investigation
he doesn't see anything in particular
but he kind of interviews a bunch of
people around there and finds out that
there was actually two more witnesses
there were these women that were out
riding horses like along the ridge or
out in that area or whatever and they
said they saw the same thing and they
described it the same way the same
newspaper article from the Deseret News
also said there was another sighting of
the same thing on August 28th and this
was by a whole family there were dairy
farmers their names were Eva and
Lawrence justice and they did an
eighteen year old son named Jimmy who
was the first one that saw it
so they described it exactly the same
way silver dome shaped objects two green
lights whole nine yards
they actually got the same impression
that it drifted off and landed someplace
so they went over there or at least the
mom went over there she said I'm gonna
go find it find out where that went and
she went over there where they thought
that it landed but there was nothing
there so they never did find anything so
that was in 1978 and like I said that
was in the real news paper and there was
a big like two or three column article
about it and everything and there was a
whole bunch of people that apparently
saw it and described it the exact same
way yeah well I'm not gonna [ __ ] on that
siding I mean there are UFOs yeah
identified yeah some of them might
actually be extraterrestrial craft you
don't know yeah so what this was I have
no idea reports I think some of these
reports are not easy to dismiss
especially when you got the military and
the police involved to see them yeah or
just massive amounts of people calling
in to 911 you know they're seeing
something in the sky like over in
Phoenix yeah and yeah there were flares
but you know the flares were after the
sighting yeah flares of the UF did the
Air Force put those flares up in the
Phoenix you guys because that was yeah
that was later as he as if you just saw
you just uh as soon as I saw the
interviews with the 911 operators I was
like yeah they saw something you're not
gonna get that many calls in and I'm
nine one one you know and then they said
the other 911 operators were getting
called so it was going it came down the
entire state yeah a wave of sightings
something was in the sky yeah some
people say it's ultralight planes with
lights on it in formation other people
say no
away yeah I mean that just because I
mean obviously a lot of people saw
something that doesn't necessarily mean
it's extraterrestrial doesn't mean it's
not but it's hard to fool a lot of
people though that's what I do if it was
obviously one thing well you don't get
that many one-on-one calls
I mean right like maybe you might get a
few from like dumb people we live near
an airport there's always airplanes in
the sky we're not calling 911 we see
yeah we have a Sanford Airport is right
here four or five miles from our house
so the planes go like pretty much right
over the house yeah and sometimes from
certain angles they look like a flying
triangle it don't know it's a plane
yeah you know so that's why sometimes if
you hear like rumbling while we're doing
the show that's what that is that's an
airplane
yeah when people are calling 911 about
it in huge numbers is because it's
unusual yeah that's a weird-looking
thing that a lot of people don't know
what it is and let's just say it was
unusual yeah and the Air Force got
involved yeah so somehow that's good
enough for me yeah yeah so I feel like
after that like I said probably if that
had been all it was like you know if
people had just seen like UFOs and like
weird lights there and [ __ ] like that
I feel like probably skinwalker ranch
would barely be a blip on the map
however then came 1994 when the Sherman
family moved in I'm not sure if this is
actually their names because I've seen
them called Terry and Gwen Sherman but
I've also seen other sources say oh
these are their pseudonyms because they
didn't want their real names getting out
I guess so apparently like I said the
Myers family had been living on
skinwalker ranch since either 1905 or
since the 1930s was a very long time
they left the ranch in 1987 I believe
that the father died and the wife was
still there but then she finally either
died or moved away or whatever so they
all left now after that the land the
homestead was empty for seven years but
then Terry Sherman comes along and buys
the property for apparently and if you
see in Amityville Horror you should know
this is a red flag right here
it's 480
Akers and he got it for like a steal
like a really really good deal you know
what I mean which yeah yeah it is desert
but apparently it was a nice piece of
land and he was like amazed he's like
wow I can't believe it was so cheap
because he would he was a cattle breeder
and a rancher and he's like he'd been
wanting to like you know breed prized
cattle and he's like this is a perfect
piece of land and he was so excited so
it was them in their two kids and they
move on to the land in summer of 1994
and they just can't believe their luck
it's just this amazing thing well I
guess it's not desert its scrub yeah
yeah I've seen it yeah yeah it's kind of
a mixture it looks like California
Southern Californian that's mostly the
desert scrub brush yeah yeah they call
it scrub yeah staging brush
stage now the story goes that the first
weird thing they noticed this is like
straight out of a haunting episode yeah
when the family moves into the house is
that the previous owners supposedly the
Myers family even though like I said I
don't as far as I know the Myers family
never reported anything weird happening
in the house are on the land or anything
in particular but apparently so they
move in and they see like the previous
owners have put deadbolt locks yeah yeah
on all the doors and windows both sides
on both sides and ones inside the house
too yeah even like the kitchen cabinets
and [ __ ] like that had dead bolts on
them so they were like huh that's a
little strange maybe they had somebody
living in the house at one time or
another that wasn't had Alzheimer's so
you had to keep them locked out yeah
maybe we are going into your room all
time
or maybe somebody was trying to be on a
diet and there's like look I'm putting
the Oreos in this kitchen cabinet not
lucky you know really kids running
around trying to pull get get into your
room trying to get off pull your [ __ ]
out of you yeah there's there are other
I mean there are other every solution
but is weird
yeah I would be a little weirded out
like if I went into the house and there
was dead bolts all over every yeah
before we go to too far into this case
this case has a [ __ ] ton of stories yeah
most of them kind of unrelated so we
can't tell them all within the scope of
one hour I'm gonna focus mostly on the
main ones on the the Sherman family the
Sherman family okay and okay
and plus I found an account of a guy who
worked there who were said he worked
there between 2003 and 2005 and he saw a
couple weird things too but and I also
want to get into like a little bit like
all the different phenomena that had
been reported yeah that was on the web
they had a whole different it's so cute
like on the website they have a whole
little thing of like all the various
things that have been reported there
yeah and just like I'm reading it and
some of it sounds kind of reasonable
like oh you know this particular light
or this particular shape UFO or whatever
and then they just get weirder weirder
you're good yeah well the places in the
moon as a paranormal hotspot so when you
go into an area like that that has a
reputation like that you probably have a
much greater propensity to keep your
eyes open for anything that's weird yeah
and even might start to notice things
that maybe seem weird so you report them
so there's always gonna be a lot more
reports around a certain place that had
a lot more reports kinda like than Butte
Bermuda Triangle yeah yeah I mean
there's a lot traffic in that area a lot
of bad stuff happens so yeah it's the
triangle I think it's more statistical
it is it's just because there's more way
more shipping lanes right in that
particular area so yeah you're gonna get
more accidents I kind of seen an
overview of the of the cases and their
reports that have happened in this area
and I think it's I think I think some of
this stuff is happening but part of it
is there's a synergy behind it yeah and
I mean people go here expecting to see
something and they they do cuz they're
looking well and like you said I think
that's the case in a lot of you know
famous haunted house yeah things too
because if a house gets a reputation for
being haunted you might make that sucker
haunted then yeah then you might it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy
cuz you're gonna go in there in any
little creek your here is gonna oh [ __ ]
that's the ghost even though if it was a
regular house you probably wouldn't even
think about it you know what I mean
right
or you might freak yourself out so badly
that it does it does become haunted who
knows maybe it might might have a
synergy that it you know I mean that
yeah you make a make a haunting to kind
of like it oh my experience in Mammoth
Mountain oh yeah something like that
because like if you expect something bad
to happen
well you might make something better
that's still paranormal I think it's
more likely though this is gonna be
something more statistical yeah but I'll
say we'll see I was here more about it
yeah so like I said other than all the
dead bolts they also noticed that
there's like a bunch of like iron steaks
with chains on them which they kind of
assumed maybe it was guard dogs don't
yeah we had those so they thought that
was a little weird too
now according to them and according to
the website on the first day they
arrived there they're you know bringing
their cattle onto the property as you do
because like I said they were cattle
breeders they put them in the pen and
they suddenly see a big-ass wolf off in
the distance is a bulletproof wolf story
yeah is there a bulletproof wolf there
ought to be I've heard I've heard it
told okay go ahead
yeah so they see a big wolf in the
distance now they think this is a little
strange because they're like oh well
supposedly there's no wolves in that
area although I would imagine there's
probably coyotes right yeah yeah I would
think there's coyotes around there but
there's not supposed to be any wolves
that wolves in this particular area and
this one looks much bigger than a normal
one now evidently they said that another
thing that was unusual about this was
that this wolf did not seem afraid of
them and it also seemed tame and kind of
friendly like you know what I mean like
nobody grassing right somebody's husky
that's what I but yea so evidently they
like started walking closer to it let
let let them pet it it wasn't aggressive
at all so then they're like wow this is
crazy so then they had some of their
cattle in the pens and one of the calves
like sticks his little head out of the
pen like going home what's that little
wolf up to blah blah blah and all this
other step now suddenly
wolf lunges at the calf and puts his
head in its mouth like cats right so
then apparently the Terri Sherman the
rancher is like okay well I guess wasn't
so friendly after all and I can't have
this cuz these are like all my expensive
prized cattle so he allegedly starts
shooting at this wolf well it hit it
first with a sticks yeah they hit it
first with sticks yeah and then now some
I've heard different accounts because
the account on the website says he just
picked up his rifle and shot at the wolf
another source I saw a sense in Magnus
said that he shot at first a whole bunch
of times with a 357 Magnum and then when
it didn't have an effect then he got the
rifle and shot and it was a 30 out six
right and supposedly like a chunk of the
wolf came off yeah yeah come out through
the exit but the wolf like acted like
nothing was happening like what are you
even doing broths like I don't yeah I
feel ya and they said they didn't see
any blood it didn't appear like it was
hurt and some sources also said that
they found the piece that they'd shot
out of the wolf but it looked like it
was all rotten and old like not from
like it was from a fresh animal yeah
okay the bulletproof wolf y'all yeah I'm
not really buying because you know and
I've actually shot a coyote before
there's a long story you know my dad and
his friends have two hunting rights on a
big piece of masonite land only five
miles where my dad lives
so man I grew up in this out Mississippi
I used to grow up every summer I used to
go down there and just shoot the [ __ ]
out of that place with 30 carbines later
on a que forty sevens and forty fives
and stuff that you know that I bought
and you know we had a little shooting
range set up there and at every deer
season we'd hunt there there's a bunch
of rules that we had you know you
couldn't shoot anything out of season of
course you know but one of the rules was
is that couldn't be any dogs or wild
dogs there because what they do is I
chase all the deer away yeah so we had
what's called cut outs for their
shooting lanes and shooting houses
and the place was just a damn kill zone
you couldn't get in and out of that area
without crossing somebody's gunsights
cuz we'd all kind of go there as a team
there was a competition going on with
other hunters and you know we weren't
shooting dos you know you don't shoot
does it unless his doe day no spikes we
need to shoot for points we had to have
six point deer or larger and we're
planting rye grass which is not the same
as baiting of course you know you can
make so you make this lush habitat and
you allow the deer to live there for a
long time so they grow big enough to
have the racks that you want all right
and of course you eat oh you eat these
deer you know that yeah you're not
shooting no fun it's you know the the
points on the racks helps but all that
meat ends up in the freezer you know we
eat that okay well you can't have dogs
there there's no civilization around
there any dog that would be there would
be some kind of a coyote or some kind of
feral dogs and what they'll do is
they'll attack or kill the young deer
you know the what do you call them
little bonds yeah and it'll drive the
deer out of your lush habitat that
you've built for them right you know so
you're not hunting these things to
extinction you're actually kind of like
growing large populations these deer and
cone them yeah you're calling off the
ones that have reproduced already yeah
you know that's kind of a big deal I
mean you said that's why you wait until
they're yeah those mammals are like
really big because they've already had
right yeah and if they if they're six
points deer they only grow two points
per year so a spike is a year old as two
spikes right four point he's two years
old six point he's three years old by
the time three years they've probably
already get her sired three or four you
know yeah next you know the first two
probably two children yeah well one day
I was in the shooting stand and saw
something running across the cutout and
I said it said a dog and but the
coloration was and this is at 150 yards
and I was man I had the worst rifle
my dad had the time as we gave me
because that's all that's all we had it
was a - it was a Remington bolt-action
222 not a 223 a 222 with a scope on it
so I put the scope on whatever it is it
was running towards me and it was some
kind of a wild animal I said I think
that's a coyote but whatever it is it
doesn't belong here it's chasing the
deer off so I had orders to shoot that
kind of stuff you know yeah and it is
Varmus so you can shoot it alright all
year-round that fired off around her and
and I heard it hit her saw it hit and
went he went yipe and jumped up about
five feet in the air after the bullet
impact he hit the ground
and I thought he was dead and I was
looking at through the scope waited a
few seconds it's getting ready to go
down there and go get him
and he stood up and looked at me and
then started to run it ran in a circle
like that and then ran away huh later on
my dad came because what did you kill
cuz he heard the shot yeah and I said
there was a coyote but it got away and
is it now you know because they had
never seen a coyote amiss in that area
yeah yeah so we went down there to where
where it was where I shot it and there
was just a ring of fur and a little bit
of blood splats and he goes you shot
something but that must have been a dog
and I said no I wasn't a dog I think it
was a coyote well years later I'm in the
army I talked to my dad and get a call
from him one time and unisys like me six
years later he goes william killed your
coyote that's like what cuz he didn't
believe me
and he goes yeah he comes to the house
goes look in the back of truck and he
says look back there and there was a
coyote with a great high that had been
filmed over yeah this is where'd you hit
it this is a sort of put the scope
basically right on its face
yeah and squeezed off around and it went
underneath the eye it just grazed him
knocked him out yeah and that was only
place it hit he kind of grated over it
made like a cataract on it and he did
have a scar there right there where I
said but later on like five or six years
later he walked out chasing deer away my
dad
I heard my dad my dad's friend William
shot it with a 308
it had gotten big but it was a coyote so
I'm hearing this story that he's telling
shooting this thing three or four times
you know and then it blowing you know if
it most please that's all [ __ ] he
was missing
yeah I'm missing eventually he probably
hit it with a 3006 but not not real well
it knocked some flesh off of it but it
walked away and they walked away cos are
stunned and it probably lived because
they're badasses well they're tough yeah
they're tough and if you don't hit the
vital organs even with the biggest with
the biggest calibers you know as long as
you don't hit by a vital organs it just
goes through them yeah it's like
piercing you know damn how many people
we know the fetish scene it appears we
know a girl I could stick spikes through
her skin of her back and suspend herself
from the ceiling like something out of
animals you know look what is that
little big man yeah man called horse leg
Indian tribes and stuff yeah she does
that no problem swings around yeah so
you know it's kind of same thing bullet
just whizzed through yeah if it goes
through I mean really the the problem is
if it hits something major or lodges in
there yes well and a rifle it can't
Lodge in it could go through ten animals
yeah the pictu inch penetration but yes
no I just heard the story and it's just
like yeah that's that's normal
normal occurrences that happen during
hunting yeah yeah you should fire a lot
of shots at close range do something you
know cuz you guys panicked he's missing
one round hits and then the animal runs
off yeah you know just because it wasn't
a good hit an animal can take it you
know even a human being can take him
could take a rifle shot if it doesn't
hit any vitals yeah you know that might
be the case well like I said I'm not
buying Bullock rupal no but I think
they're trying to imply that this is a
skinwalker no they're trying to imply
that but come on I know I don't well I
don't believe it either yeah but uh
evidently this same very large wolf was
also seen later on by like a few days
later by Gwen the wife she said she was
in her car and she
the wolf and it was as tall she said the
back was parallel with the top of her
window so this is like a pretty big
animal evidently that she saw I don't
know how far away it was when she saw it
so evidently like over the next couple
of years you know cuz like I said they
moved in a 1994 so from 1994 to 1996
they supposedly see a bunch of other
unusual animals cryptids whatever you
want to call them like around the area
some of their neighbors apparently
reported them to some of the weirdest
was like some of us saw Bigfoot or
sasquatches or whatever some of them
said they saw like strange like
multicolored birds that were not native
to that area which that's not that weird
I mean they could have escaped from who
knows where like a pet store or a zoo or
something like that I mean [ __ ] like
that does happen it's happened around
here we had like some monkeys escaped
from in Florida they had like a little
they made a little um you know a little
community and they just like howler
monkeys and they just sit up in the tree
and make a lot of noise but they just
escaped from zoos and then reproduced
monkeys are no big deal yeah that's the
foreign version of a squirrel oh you see
squirrels have around here they're they
act on awful lot like a monkey they got
the same job yeah yeah that's the monkey
niche run around trees yeah
teas are cat yeah Mike like make funny
little bird noise yeah yeah they also
said they saw a strange creature that
looked something like a hyena except
they said it was about 200 pounds so
it's kind of big they said it was
heavily muscled low-to-the-ground
had curly red hair and a bushy tail so
not a chupacabra it goes back to that
misidentification and seeing animals you
know what I mean fleeting glimpses of
animals and then not really sure what it
was you saw like when I saw that coyote
you know that they weren't common in
those days yeah this is when I was a kid
yeah and they didn't believe me but
later on years later they became common
there yeah animal you're not expecting
to see or that you've never seen in the
wild before maybe like yeah you're gonna
especially if it's kind of far away you
may like yeah and they had dad migrated
into Mississippi from those more desert
type regions yeah because of humans you
know humans moved into those reasons and
there were still a lot of stuff out in
Mississippi they could live in no bear
though which is awful strange you got
[ __ ] ton of bear around here we got him
in our backyard I know but I think I've
said that on the show before [ __ ] we
came home to the club one day the big
big ol bear sitting right in the
driveway and like he was waiting for us
to come home Mississippi the perfect
place for bear but they're not there
yeah maybe there's not enough garbage
cans cuz really that's the only thing
these bears care about is those garbage
cans yeah they loved those girls they
don't work scavengers yeah they don't
work for a living all they gotta do is
like figure out they had to give us like
where we live now you got special
garbage okay I had to give a special
garbage you're not allowed to have
normal garbage kids anymore like to put
your thing out on the curb you have to
have this one with like the lock on it
because they said the Bears were getting
in there and like they were scaring
people and whatnot so yeah we you have
to have the one with the lock on it so
funny most people are scared of them you
know not gonna hurt you they're not
gonna hurt you it's foreign people
they're really scared to come from other
countries you know like India they don't
they see a bear they've only seen bears
in the movies and they just think
they're not grizzly yeah they think it a
grizzly bear it's gonna come in the
house gonna kill them I mean grizzly
bears will [ __ ] you up these things are
the cutest things ever even when they're
big you know they're still to me they're
cute they are cute yeah they're not
there and they're very chill yeah right
sure yeah they can't kill you but they
don't you know what I mean yeah they're
there darah
they're a complexed animal and they have
a good intelligence which means there's
variation in them every now and then
there's a bad bear in the same way they
every now and then there's a bad person
yeah you know but they're not even
defensive of young that's a myth brown
bear and grizzly are but not black bear
you can grab a black bear cub right in
front of the mama the Mamas just ignores
you I got it on video
as long as as soon as they're used to
people in it you know they know people
aren't a threat or you know yeah I mean
like they just hang out yeah we're
hanging up neighborhoods
you're like a big they're even more
friendly than a dinner raccoon a raccoon
will tear you up but you can make
friends with a raccoon yeah I got videos
of that people Patton royal raccoons
feeding them you know yeah when they
realize that you'll feed them all of a
sudden yeah then they'll come in your
[ __ ] little cat flap yeah come in
there with their little hands out yeah
I've seen videos y-yeah wild raccoons
sleeping up on a guy's windowsill you
know just fat from you just sleeping he
said yeah and in he's saying yeah he's
my buddy he's been coming here for four
months
oh so you know I think yeah I think it's
funny because whatever sometimes we let
the cats run around and like on the back
porch and stuff and every now and then
like a big raccoon will walk by and
they'll like look at him like and they
try to like make little buddies with it
and stuff but the raccoons are like nope
but yeah so apparently so Terri Sherman
says that this particular hyena looking
thing with the bushy tail disappeared
before his eyes so like I said this is
supposedly like some kind of
supernatural [ __ ] going on here so now
is now we're getting into the realm of
cattle disappearances and cattle
mutilations because at this stage right
around spring of 1995
Terry says he starts to notice some of
his cattle are disappearing you know he
asked around all the neighbors and then
no one's seen them they seem to have
wandered off or they seem to have been
killed they seem to turn up dead and he
said they usually serve seem to turn up
dead like right after they see some type
of weird UFO thing so he says in spring
of 1995 was the first time he saw like a
UFO type thing on the property he said
he was out looking at his cattle and he
saw a silent glowing object that kind of
hovered over this really like a stand of
poplar trees that was around the outside
of one of the fields is that Katie
what's that Kitty doing
she's tearing up a tree okay yeah so
they said and it was they said it was
super bright like it lit up the whole
side of the mountain and that every time
that they would see this then like later
on like the next day or something like
that they would find one of
cows dead damn kitty but um they said
that one of the cows they found like
after this particular UFO sighting they
said they didn't find any injuries on it
anywhere except there was a hole in the
center of its left eyeball and evidently
they took a piece of wire and stuck it
into the eyeball and it went all the way
into the brain so you're getting some
like some of the aliens are coming like
pouring out the cow from the eyeball
I guess I'm very skeptical of the cattle
mutilation phenomenon it just seen a lot
of dead animals and I know how I see I
saw I saw a dead deer moving in the
middle of the road I'm going what the
hell is wrong with that deer armadillo
came running out of its ass all right
Yeah right and I'm very you're very
familiar with this with that process
apart what happens to animals once they
die now if they've been sitting there
for a little while all this stuff about
coring out the cow's ass I've seen those
photographs and that's not what's
happening you know and the eye thing the
ID it's exposed usually gets eaten by
birds pretty quickly yeah things will
run down a cow's ass and core it out the
armadillos and [ __ ] all right
armadillos Rosie yeah they're gross they
will eat anything
yeah also some of the stuff that they
say it looks like it's laser precision
cut not really what it is it might be a
single hole and then as decomposition
happens it kind of expands out to look
very round yeah and you just you know
it's a case-by-case basis you know Elsa
was shown pictures from the skinwalker
ranch of oh this animal you know this
this wasn't done by by this animal
wasn't eaten by other animals this was
done by you know some kind of laser
precision and I'm looking at him going
know that was eaten by animals that's
what it looks like you know I've seen it
yeah you think they would do better they
don't want to know better maybe they
don't yeah I think it sells more it
sells more to say
I think at first it started I think I
think when the phenomenon first appeared
it was ignorance it was guys that have
not seen too many dead things yeah and
don't know much about ecology and how
there's a whole ecosystem Nature has a
huge cleanup crew of insects and birds
and animals that come and just eat
anything else your body just do weird
[ __ ] to you you know insects do it too
you know and it all happens pretty
quickly nothing doesn't anything that
dies it's not there for very long
yeah even something pretty big it's not
there long yeah it is I mean in this
area if something's killed on the road
it's only there for a few hours
buzzards get it oh yeah that's like
woohoo and then they drag it over to the
dragon office every day they pull it
aside a road over there fighting and
pulling something apart and all their
buddies come and if they don't have
buzzards in the area it's other
creatures that are gonna be doing it and
it happens pretty fast yeah I threw a
dead turkey out one time that died I was
I was working in a in dr. Matt's barn
yeah and went there one morning and
found that the turkey had died through
the turkey out the back I said I'll get
him later bury him and after I got done
with what I had to do in the bar and
went back out there to go bury him he
was gone they'd already taken him I
don't know what and that was only about
two hours some little animal walked by
another guy it's my lucky day gives off
all these chemicals that humans can't
smell it but animals that that are
scavengers can they know the smell of
something that's dead they come again is
just like ringing the dinner bell they
come and we're not in a Content area
really yeah
we're on the outsides of a suburban area
yeah weird yeah it's like it's kind of I
wouldn't even call it whirl it was a
girl at one time they want to make it
seem like it's rural and it is there's
like a lot of woods and stuff around
there's a lot of animals we see deer we
see bears all the time
all the time but I mean the city is like
right there doctor highway is like right
there dr. Matt and he only lives right
up the street here yeah and he's got a
piece of land with a mansion on it and a
barn and some arenas and round pins for
the horses and he's got a bunch of
horses there and and it's got driveways
to go through it looks like a little
miniature version of Walt Disney World
so what it looks yeah and at one time
that was a country home but that was 20
years ago the area has built up quite a
bit now we're in a suburban area it's
built up since we I mean we've lived in
this house for what seven years seven
years and there's a lot of stuff that's
been built in this area seven and a half
years something like that it's it's not
right it's almost unrecognizable in
certain areas around this house yeah
housing complexes yeah they built a [ __ ]
ton of houses like just behind ours
you'll see bare you'll still see I see
him running through people's yards yeah
yeah we just saw him wandering it up
with a couple days and it was the size
of a large dog and I told oh say how you
doing bear remember it was in there in
that it was going up into somebody's
garage in our neighborhood cuz I said
maybe we should tell the people that
there's a bear looking right at the
refrigerator because had a refrigerator
in the garage like oh because to us have
two refrigerators they can open those
he'll open refrigerator right up there's
like they're as smart as a monkey yeah
I've seen a book refrigerators yeah he
can open a car door
that's ooh yeah okay so like I said
counts disappearing cattle mutilations
bla bla bla um
teri said that at one time he was like
he lost one cow but he saw its tracks so
he followed its tracks and the tracks
suddenly disappeared like in the snow
like the cow had been sucked up into a
[ __ ] I guess whatever um so now
they're saying they're seeing now
they're starting to see all these like
UFOs and [ __ ] like that then he starts
saying that they see what are
essentially portals in the sky maybe we
should leave that for the second half
yeah maybe it's probably about time to
take a break so cuz this is I mean if
the [ __ ] was unbelievable before the
is where it starts going wildly off the
red yeah so yeah well yeah and don't get
mad I mean you know I believe that there
are paranormal things that happen it's
just that not everything is reported as
paranormal not everything is legitimate
yeah and I'm not saying that they didn't
see stuff and UFOs are not paranormal
extraterrestrials that's part of the
natural world well yeah from another
planet right yeah so that's there's
nothing worried about that they just
came from a big deal and I and I think
that at least I think that well I'm
gonna try to be political about it I
think I think that not all of these UFO
sightings can be easily dismissed
well that's a good thing right I mean
you're not necessarily coming out and
saying yeah I think that I got a
suspicion based on a lot of I got a
suspicion that yeah that
extraterrestrial craft and you come here
every now and then yeah I don't think
it's real common though and I don't
think they're real interested in I said
why would they yeah and here's another
thing
now the government probably knows what's
happening they I don't think they know
anything more than what we know not much
where they're not talking to him yeah
yeah I don't think there's any kind of
like big cover I'm not anything like
that like even if they are like cry
every now and then they might be
covering up the fact that they know that
they come here but that's not anything
about it right that's right yeah because
why the [ __ ] would they talk to her they
said why wouldn't there they would never
admit things were violating our airspace
that they couldn't control they would
never come out and say yeah
extraterrestrials come here and there's
nothing we can do about it we don't know
what they want we don't know who they
are they never say that they could have
a big death range yeah they would say
yeah we don't care about that or that's
not happening that's what they would say
probably alright so we're going to take
a break right now when we come back like
I said we're inside about portals we're
gonna talk about more crazy [ __ ] that
they saw and all of the different
manifestations the different paranormal
[ __ ] that it's supposedly been seen over
the years on skinwalker ranch so we will
be back in just a few minutes
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest
unsolved murders of the 20th century vol
2 in
it's cases spanning the years from 1960
through 1979 featuring such infamous
crimes as the triple homicide at Lake
Bodom the family massacre known as the
good heart murders the serial killings
of the Zodiac Bible John Jack the
stripper and the freeway phantom the
slaughter of dozens of women and girls
along the highway of tears and the Texas
killing fields and the mysterious death
of suspected spy the is doll woman along
with dozens of other fascinating and
horrifying accounts buy it now from
Amazon in print Kindle or audiobook
format so baby cookie is fascinated that
we have a squirrel in the background and
she keeps coming in here and talk tea
and she's talking to me trying to get me
to open the door so she can go in there
and play with her you know you leave the
baby alone that squirrel is hurt I know
but you came in okay I've never heard
you talk so much why are you so excited
yeah okay you're not going in there
though yeah okay everybody ginnis guys a
new shirt designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah it
really good they're very high quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put a spotlight on ourselves
and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
on these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them mix in the description WWL
calm at 13 o'clock yes ago check out our
store at wwl calm slash 13 o'clock we
got these four cool new t-shirt designs
plus all our old ones if you'd rather
get one of the old ones but these ones
are awesome and you should check them
out they're also available in women's
cut they look really cute JT's got some
so thank you go check them out
all right we're back butter and port
alized dogs or is it portals and butter
eyes okay
the second thing I have to tell you that
I love like I said I went to the actual
skinwalker ranch official I guess it's
the official last web site for this
place and I was kind of reading the
timeline and like all the stories about
it and stuff like that and I have to say
I really loved that this portion of the
story had the subhead blue balls and
butter eyes dogs okay and I'm like are
you guys trolling me
yeah cuz that's pretty fun that's what's
on there we need a shirt that says that
blue balls in there yeah shows kind of
running late we're already in our second
hour but I guess you guys don't mind
yeah our shows are getting longer longer
because we're getting more and more
drunk and long-winded there's a lot of
stuff a lot of different little reports
in this yes I mean like I said I was
mostly focusing on this section because
this is where the crazy [ __ ] is you know
and I got a couple reports from some
people that were there supposedly there
later and like I said I want to go into
a little bit like all the different [ __ ]
that's supposedly been seen there but so
at this stage the schurmans are still
there they said they're still seeing
little crafts little cattle mutilation
situations going on and then they start
seeing this other crazy [ __ ] now listen
to this now this is a quote from terry
sherman he says we would see these
hundred foot 100-foot circular openings
appear in the air it was like four
orange colored doorways would sort of
spiral open portal to another dimension
y'all that's what he's talking about so
evidently they would see these appear in
the sky they would get there like their
binoculars their high-powered scope
through whatever and look at them and
they said now out of these portals would
come like smaller crafts that were like
60 by 40 feet they were kind of square
shaped then they had like little short
wings and they would come out and like
fly around like in a grid type formation
and then they had like these little
spikes of light which would come out and
like hit the ground which they got the
impression with something like
navigational system or they were doing
what you
was this again this was mid-90s they
were still there in the mid-90s they
well they only lived there for like two
years right okay right so yeah they're
seeing all that kind of [ __ ]
they also comment well I'm just
wondering okay let's see there are some
cards yeah there are extra dimensional
beings that want to monitor the Earth's
progress why are these portals opening
up over such an insignificant place
you gotta mean basically the desert is
always an significant basically think
about it wouldn't it just know like
whatever I don't believe you but only
saying it you know this might what you
know okay on the outside what possibly
could be going on is maybe there's some
kind of extra dimensional aliens or
something that want to see secret
technology that's happening on one of
those Air Force bases in the area yeah
maybe but come on come on listen think
about this if these extraterrestrials
can actually pass through dimensional
doors there's one thing they may be
working there's nothing we could be
working on that they wouldn't know about
what you care about that always makes me
skeptical bedrocks because why would
they care they can do all that why would
they care a good analogy would be like
humans in the 60s putting together the
Apollo moon rocket yet I mean to go see
what some tribes men on the other side
of the world are doing with those
obsidian arrowheads let's see what
common that's a good analogy see what
kind of city of arrowheads they're
making in that tribe over there yeah it
wouldn't be going on yeah then we're
gonna add some woman sticks up stuff up
there alright listen let me look at it
from this angle
okay maybe they saw something all right
maybe if something did happen there they
misidentified it whatever it was maybe
it was something else so when a weird
atmospheric they maybe it was peyote
but I don't know it's just I think I
think it's a fabrication think about it
it's too grandiose if look if you're
going to just approach it if you're
gonna come up with like a paranormal
story to you know whatever you want to
do just to get attention or whatever um
probably keep it kind of low key well
because the crazier it gets I feel like
the less people or not I mean no man I
mean sick [ __ ] man Mountain poltergeist
is pretty [ __ ] crazy but that way it
wasn't that happen though I know but
that wasn't crazy to the extent I mean
mostly what that was I mean that was
like stuff moving around but it was like
mundane stuff moving Oh tears and towels
and [ __ ] there wasn't any rhyme or
reason to it right and you didn't see no
like any [ __ ] no no dimension door
opened up happened to me that tried to
convey the Akashic records or you know
no yeah that's no it didn't want to
communicate whatever it was well I think
I know what it is but you got to read
the book yeah well we didn't show about
it yeah but yeah so right around this
time that they started seeing these
supposed portals like appearing in this
guy with all these little smaller ships
like supposedly coming out of them also
him in the Sun Terry in the Sun also
reported hearing voices coming out of
thin air like when they were out in the
fields these later became known by later
researchers as the collectors or the
what do they call it the [ __ ] I don't
remember what they're called now but I
don't get to it later are the
controllers rather not the collectors I
was thinking of that control the
controllers now these are apparently two
male voices that are talking to each
other it sounds like it's coming over a
CB radio but it is in fact coming out of
thin air is that the field they're not
speaking English they're speaking in
some language that they that Terry did
not recognize he said it sounded very
choppy and halting he said it sounded
kind of like maybe Russian or like a
Native American type dialect he couldn't
really put his finger on what it was but
he said these two guys were talking to
each other he got the impression that
they were talking about him and he said
the first time that he and his son heard
it that he
actually like listen to them talking for
him that first they thought it was like
a like an echo of a CB radio or
something but then when they realized it
was coming out of thin air he said
something like hey we can hear you and
then it's the voices stopped and then he
heard like a laugh and then the voices
kept on going okay so there was that
whole thing now the next big thing that
happened apparently now this was
something that Gwen the wife saw now she
says that she saw lights out in the
field one evening so she goes and gets
her binoculars and she goes and looks
over where the lights are coming from
now she sees what she called a square
lighted structure and it's sitting on
the ground is that what has landed now
she says before the light goes out she
says she saw you're gonna laugh she saw
a large heavyset individual that's a
quote and he was seated in the object
right like she sucks like through the
binoculars binoculars all right so then
she saw that and then like later on she
sees it again and then her and the
husband Terry also saw it they looked at
it through like a big like a
high-powered scope or whatever now they
see the same object and then they see a
figure standing next to it which is
apparently over seven feet tall wearing
a black uniform and appearing they said
he either had a helmet on or his face
was like metallic or something because
it was like this weird like shiny [ __ ]
like happening around his facial type
area so yes so they're seeing a person
sitting in the lighted box or later what
happened to it it's like sitting in
their field
um not super sure I guess it just kind
of vanished or took off or whatever but
they reported that also now another
thing that they reported on more than
one occasion was the blue balls yeah not
the kind of blue balls that you're
probably thinking about yeah these were
literal balls so they see these glowing
blue balls like kind of floating around
the property they give off a crackling
sound they seem as though they someone
is controlling them like perhaps by
remote control they seem like to be
moving in
telogen wait years this is mid nineties
still like I said they only lived there
from like 94 to 96 all just happen is in
two year period yes it was a busy two
years as you can see so they see these
kind of balls they describe them as they
were kind of like blue balls about the
size of a baseball he said there were
two like blue colored fluids inside of
it it looked like they were kind of like
intermingling with each other he said
what they would do was they would kind
of hover above the ground and they would
kind of hover like over to the animals
like it would hover in front of the cow
and like look at its face like it was
checking it out they'd seen their probes
yeah or it would go over to the horses
and check it out or whatever now
evidently about of all the things they
saw these blue balls like scared Terry
the most he said he said because they
were obviously he said they look like
they were checking [ __ ] out now the
straw that broke the camel's back came
from these little black but from these
little blue balls so apparently there's
some of them hovering in the field one
night they kind of hover like near a cow
and then they it kind of goes off a
little bit and then three of the
schurmans dogs took off running like
after the blue ball right like it kind
of went off in the field or whatever and
the blue balls went off and chased it so
and it's funny because these are their
dogs the dogs run off after the blue
ball and apparently the schurmans are
just like well the dogs I'm sure they'll
be fine or I'm too scared to go check
we'll go check in the morning when it's
light out so the next morning they go
out where the blue ball was they see
three like scorched areas of Earth and
in the middle of each of these scorched
areas of Earth is like a smear of like
something that they described is looking
like butter or shortening which they
assume are the remains of their dear
departed dogs which they obviously never
found ever again I'm not sure why they
immediately jump to that conclusion I
don't know if the shortening looked like
shape I'm not really sure what that's
all about but like I said this is why
the subhead of this particular story was
called butter butter eyes dog
come on aliens leave the docks alone
don't wrap this these are the dogs into
shortening that's not cold I'm just not
really buying this aspect of the case
just like this sounds like some crazy
Sheriff yeah yeah okay what else yeah so
they said them just think this is all
very implausible I don't think extra
dress of be interested in people's dogs
or turn people's dogs people's dogs are
de like crazy oh that's cool
these are tall tales these are tall
tales now I'm not saying there's no UFOs
in that area maybe somebody saw some
UFOs earlier which we know that they did
yeah they have new people coming into
the scene already with you know yeah
there's UFOs they show up here yeah
everybody's seeing them oh we saw some
matter of fact I saw some two blue balls
you know just it's no now what else is
there so apparently the butter eyes dogs
it's just it's just where the final
straw it's very 80s that story very 70s
and 80s the Sherman's were finally
finally at long last we're like yeah
we're getting the [ __ ] out of here
yeah so they go to now evidently at this
stage teri talks to some of the ute
Indian tribes people that are in the
area and they said oh yeah you know we
know how [ __ ] up that land is and like
all kind of weird [ __ ] happens we have
like an ongoing bet like whoever moves
out of that land we have a bet like how
long they're gonna stay this is this
this is the part that bothers ya you
have stories of basically Native
American werewolves that go back yeah to
the 1900s and then you have stories
about UFOs as if UFOs are somehow linked
to this cursed land yeah I'm having
problems with this you know I mean it's
almost kind of like a lot remember how
you know some paranormal things that
I've seen like documentaries and stuff
try to link UFO sightings with like
Sasquatch it was sasquatch that yeah and
it's like I'm not really sure what like
Oh sasquatches from out of habit you
have a theory okay they can that people
say that they see a sasquatch
all right then they go and check and
there's no footprints
so therefore
Sasquatch is not a physical creature
it's a supernatural spiritual creature
all right and then UFOs are in fall
involved - yeah I mean somehow I don't
really get that because the origin of
these stories came from very different
mindsets and very different cultures
okay
you had stories of Sasquatch type things
going all the way back to the times of
President Teddy Roosevelt Theodore
Roosevelt claimed to have had contact
with I guess a sasquatch yeah they were
around the campfire and if they heard
something out there again they threw a
rock and then the rocks and horrible cry
of a beast man type thing they I think
he said they kind of saw its outline and
I think from what I remember I you know
it was so there were stories of wild
beast man sasquatch things going going
down in the United States for a long
long time that is Native American okay
then later you had guys who are hoaxes
and it was with you know big footprints
you know they're known hoaxers they
found the feet they did okay and the
gorilla suits those guys that were
faking that and doing the Sasquatch gig
okay yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] about ghosts or
UFOs if that was a different gig yeah
but now you got guys in the industry
they want to merge all that in together
well it's kind of like scientists that
want to find a theory of everything yeah
it's like if you're into the paranormal
it's like you want some big grand rut
overarching thing wrong compasses every
single weird thing ever you know I mean
right I feel like people want to they
like that synergy they like Sasquatch
stories were we're about biology you
know this is a living creature yeah in
nature that was the intent of that story
and you know it may be true I think it's
unlikely at this point but it may have
been true in the past that might be some
kind of ancestral memory
encoded into us through something like
Gigantopithecus or me yeah when there
were other home and there were other
hominids around that we had to compete
directly with there may have been this
instilled in bred fear in us that there
were other men in the woods that were
bigger and stronger and had more hair on
them at one time that was true it was so
that it's demonstrable true yeah
and animals are born with instincts
I don't see why humans aren't born with
instincts when I was a little boy I
could remember things that I couldn't
that's me that's isn't this might be a
story from a nut for another show but
when I was a little kid I said thanks to
my dad that used to blow his mind
then I told him I said we won't is when
I was little we were on that tractor in
the tractor fell over don't you remember
that and my dad was looking and look I
mean I was like three or four and he's
shaking his head and he told my mom he
goes he goes I've never been attracted
with him he's talking about the time me
and my dad were on a tractor and the
tractor fell down fell over so
reincarnation
no no what if I inherited some kind of a
memory of that from my dad in other
words I didn't get it from a granddad
yeah even heritage that memory from my
dad and maybe those memories are thrown
away as you get older so you might be
born with some memories
inherited from your ancestors in the way
like an instant I have a feeling cuz you
know it's just like encoded like yeah
like computer right and and I don't
think the memories are real solidly
ingrained in your mind they're quickly
replaced with new memories yes like an
impressionist like an impression the
temporary thing to get you through
because a lot of people have stories
about that like up there little kid
saying freaky [ __ ] that they don't know
what happened to them but they open the
exactly their grandparents I think we
can hair it some memory but as you get
older it's replaced
yeah because maybe it's just maybe it's
some kind of glitch maybe it's really
not even maybe it's just in there and so
if that happens what's to say we don't
inherit you know pretty deeply instilled
fears
about things that just aren't a threat
anymore like big hairy guys yeah that
you know out in the woods that are twice
your size yeah you know because like you
said that did did exist some point
because there were different hominids
yeah our ancestors were fighting with
other and saying that they're gone now
but yeah and like I said I've always
said that of all the quote unquote
paranormal topics and I'm not saying
that I think they're likely but the most
likely are UFOs because like you said it
would just be another species from
another planet which that's not that
crazy or sasquatches because it would
just be an animal if there's a sasquatch
it's got in the United States it's gonna
be up in up in Washington State yeah
it's gonna be up in Canada it's not
gonna be down this far so I don't even
really consider that and then another
thing is is that you're talking about
sasquatch there's a possibility that the
o-ring pendick might exist yeah there
been some educated people that have seen
it go yeah that's it's all ring pen
decades and they said it's a small
hominid it's a it's a lucky' bipedal
yeah you know but that's like there have
been people that yeah I mean they found
fossils of those and that wasn't that
long ago you know though the Hobbit
people the hobbit thing is a hominid
it's a it's it's from our genus you know
yeah I don't think Oh ring pendick is I
think it's a I think it's a bipedal
chimpanzee yeah you know like I said
that's not that's not that far off yeah
it's a cousin not so much you know the
ancestor but yes so okay like I saw you
know for people who are new to the show
we're not bagging on all this [ __ ] yeah
man I do believe that there's a lot of
that a lot of this stuff at least
there's a possibility for it and
something I think is real is one of it I
know poltergeist is well yeah how do bad
experience I know I've had it I've had a
near-death experience and I've you know
and and I'll tell you what out of OBE
and NDE is very similar to the situation
you have in a life-or-death situation
like when you hear people saying to
having a car accident it was seemed like
it was happening in slow motion
I've had that too you know coming off
that motorcycle at seven he feels like
it's happening in slow motion it's an
altered state of consciousness well NDE
and OBE are like that too they have that
same kind of weird quality yeah you know
you've ever had that happen to you yeah
a couple times we do see it happen in
slow motion it's kind of like a weird
altered state OBE is kind of like that
yeah so is NDE but it's very different
in terms of like what it actually goes
down and it the situation but I'm like
fascinated by all that kind of like
alter consciousness okay no brains like
process like certain information well I
got some of the greatest scientists in
the world trying to figure out what
consciousness is
and yet rules may be very different it's
really right so just kind of
mind-blowing when you think and you know
based on my experience with the
poltergeist and in DNA consciousness
does alter reality physical things can
be altered through consciousness but
that's sort of story for another shelf
yeah and some quantum physics kind of
seems to support that idea too yeah that
is I think poltergeists would be an
extreme version of it yeah because it
doesn't seem to happen it doesn't happen
that often
so okay at this point like I said
they're dogs
turning to Crisco was apparently the
last straw so they said okay we're gonna
get the [ __ ] out of this ranch they'd
been there about two years so they're
gonna move out they pack up all their
cattle and stuff like that now according
to them on the last night before they
left the ranch
you know they fell asleep as they
usually did after they packed up they
were really tired and everything like
that they woke up the next day and there
was like blood all over their bed and
they saw that both Terry and Gwen said
they had like a little plug of flesh
like taken out of their thumbs as there
someone had come in and done that it was
like blood all of it I'm saying I'm just
telling you man don't make that face at
me it's not me salines don't need
bucking samples from human beings they'd
only need a sample from one human being
and they know it because we're all about
the same so they only need to sample
from so at this stage they're like okay
well we want to get the [ __ ] out of here
so at this stage comes in Robert Bigelow
who is a millionaire from Las Vegas and
he's very into like paranormal stuff and
UFO research and stuff like that he's
heard about like all these weird things
happening at this particular race so he
wants to purchase it now most of the
sources I said purchase said he
purchased it for less than the schurmans
had paid for it I believe he paid about
$200,000 for 480 acres which that's
good deal doesn't it yeah there was like
there was a house on it and [ __ ] like
that
yeah I have you seen that house to see
photographs of it well I'm not sure if
that was the original Myers house
because here's what I because the Myers
apparently built a house on it in either
1905 or in the 1930s but then later on
some houses built there but then later
on they built another house okay
property so I'm not sure if that's the
impossible I saw I saw - yeah I saw
photographs of two houses that are
associated one of them was a dump it
look gave us just Falls yeah I know
which ones and there was a newer one
that looked like it was built sometime
in the 60s okay which wasn't quite as
bad right but whether nice house it was
just a house house yeah like a country
house you know oh you know he wasn't too
stylish yeah so evidently Bigelow buys
this property and he makes the Sherman
sign a nondisclosure agreement because
evidently he's gonna open up like kind
of a paranormal research type where you
have a research thing like on there I'm
already which is called the National
Institute for discovery science or knids
which is not is all non-disclosure okay
let me they need to be honest with it
with the listeners now the
non-disclosure might be Bigelow telling
them look you guys got to shut the [ __ ]
up cuz if you guys go out there and
start running your mouth you're gonna
blow the gig yeah okay it might be that
because if you you guys are not credible
or if you go out there and say something
that's not credible it might spoil you
know what I got going but I got ya I
gotta keep this story over here straight
yeah which means to me that there's a
chance okay I'm just gonna say piccolo
didn't find those people incredible
that's what that was all about like I
said I find it credible you know but
that doesn't mean that weird [ __ ] wasn't
happening there because other people had
seen some stuff yeah and there were some
UFO sightings that date way back so it
might be the Bigelow wasn't too
interested in what this family had to
say right Bigelow might have been
interested in the place for something
else
yeah develop his drones maybe he thought
UFOs were going there maybe he believes
you know what I mean yeah so I have a
feeling that Bigelow probably didn't
really care too much about what this fan
said maybe not cuz like I said a lot of
us seems like most of the reports prior
to the Sherman's moving in we're mostly
just UFO type reports I would think of
is probably their first off but mostly
UFOs I bet you big was there for the UFO
stuff or for just to have a big piece of
property that no one can really get a
good look at so he could develop stuff
yes because once he you know started
this Institute I mean it's like he kind
of walled off the street he put like
keep outside observation towers he
brings in scientists veterinarian's blah
blah blah he apparently sent out a bunch
of letters to like ranchers in the area
like asking them about cattle
mutilations and about need their missing
animals like they were interested in
that kind of stuff so he's there for the
UFOs he's not there for yeah he's not
there for the werewolves right yeah and
there were some rumors that maybe there
was some CIA involvement you know that
they had like this retired Army colonel
that had worked for at Los Alamos like
come in there and ship at that like this
pleasure you know look I'm not an expert
on on this guy you know but if I
remember correctly Bigelow made drones
made drones for the government yeah I
think did you find that I'm not entirely
sure so I'm not gonna say one way okay I
was under the impression that he was a
contractor and that he was developing
drones for the military okay which that
would make sense of why he would want
that property yeah that'd make a good
test facility now that doesn't mean he
hasn't believe in UFOs I think he's one
of those guys that does well clearly
because he seems to be super interested
just because you're making drums doesn't
mean you don't believe in UFOs
yeah a guy that what's his name guy uh
leer believes in that too
yeah okay guy made Learjet his son he
believed totally believes in UFOs now I
forgot his first name but I don't
believe mr. leer knows too much about
what he's talking about though
maybe I've seen interviews with him and
he he's doesn't strike me as to be
he's kind of nerdy when it comes to the
UFOs yeah yeah although who am i I mean
this maybe this dude maybe he knows
maybe you know some I don't know you
know right
so also around this time like I said
after Bigelow bought the ranch other
people who lived in the area started
reporting like a lot of helicopter
activity around the area I got your you
know famous black helicopter you got
some red helicopters that had like black
cylinders like underneath them like
carrying various things and military
helicopters that type of thing so no one
knows what that's all about but
apparently some of the locals reported
that now one interesting thing that I
found on the website this guy evidently
and they I guess they copy and pasted
this from his blog this guy said that he
worked on the skinwalker ranch from 2003
to 2005 like off and on he said now I
wasn't part of the knids team but he's
like they brought in like outside
contractors to do various work around
the ranch and stuff like that he's like
so he's like so I kind of thought that I
was being hired on to like you know do
like watch for UFOs it [ __ ] like that's
why I was really excited about it he's
like but when you know at this point
like most of the activity you know that
the Sherman's had reported I guess is
what he's talking about
had died down so he's like yes that's
instructive yes so this guy said so most
of the time he's like so I'm just
sitting around like being he's like
pretty much a glorified ranch hand
quoting wood that's what he said he's
like you know I would feed the dogs I
would just go around and check all the
fences and he's like all that kind of
stuff it's like mostly we just kind of
sat around playing cards and shooting
the [ __ ] and stuff like that he's like
so he's like but I did see a couple of
weird things like while he was working
there he did see something that looked
like I believe it kind of looked like a
big black like orb or something like out
in the sky that was kind of like flying
like over that must be daytime yet well
I don't know I don't know if no cuz he
said it was night because he said it was
like a darker orb like against the
nights
like he saw it like and he said I only
talked for about 45 seconds but it kind
of like made everything worth it he also
reported a little bit of poltergeist
activity he's like he's like I had a set
of keys for the dog pens he's like cuz
that was one of my duties as I would go
out in the morning in the evening and
I'd feed all the dogs he's like so I
come in in the morning you know and I
put the keys on the table where I always
put them then he's like the you know
then I do my regular [ __ ] during the day
he's like later on I come back to get
the keys no one else has been in the you
know in the trailer or wherever it was
it's like the keys are gone we look
everywhere I get all my teammates we
look all over the place we can't find
the keys anyplace he's like then later
on he comes bet they come back and the
keys are like back on the table again so
that's like pretty classic like
poltergeist activity there could have
been something the team phone trick it
could have been although he said that
you know everybody probably get a little
more credence because you know what for
classic pokes guys stuff to happen you
have to have a young kid there I'm not
sure how old this guy is um I just like
kind of read his thing idea I got the
impression that he was a young guy but I
wasn't really sure I'd be more apt to
believe his story about seeing some some
something dark up in the sky in the
nighttime sky that sounds like maybe
somebody working on a drone right there
yeah someone a surveillance drone but he
said that um he said actually in 2004
that he saw he said he was sitting in
the trailer with like the knids people
and he said he heard the dog start going
nuts outside so they all run out there
and he said that there was like a ball
of light like going by he said it buzz
by the dog pen and then went through the
field like then then a couple of hundred
yards he said after a couple a couple
hundred yards the ball curved in and
flew off in a different direction and
then just winked out so he did off in
the direction in the sky yeah I guess so
he motorcycles by night you know yeah so
yes so that was um he saw like a couple
little UFO things there but he does say
that by the time that I started working
there like all the crazy [ __ ] like I
said that the schurmans are reporting
had pretty much died down although there
was so so far basically he said to me
isn't that great
yeah that's what I mean that's not that
crazy so that's why I kind of like this
guy you know yeah he could be making it
up but if he was making it up you'd
think he would make up something more
exciting than what he saw he said cuz
most of the time he was just sitting
around doing nothing he's a possible
explanations he's seeing drones he may
have seen motorcycles go dirt bikes
going by the pen at night could be but
you know many different things yeah I
mean that doesn't necessarily mean
extraterrestrial craft yeah but you know
whatever
okay that's part of the game and he said
another thing too was that he's like we
did try to take pictures of the stuff um
he's like but he's like I wasn't on the
nudes team so I don't know what
eventually happened to the photos he's
like I did see some of them like after
they were taken but the photos were
always really shitty right you know I
mean he's like they didn't look like
anything it just like blurry lights like
on the [ __ ] right so he's like so I
don't know if like [ __ ] was being
suppressed or if they kept the photos or
if they were like you know researching
them or whatever he's like I wasn't
privy to any of that and anything like
that so he's like though there was one
night in mid September of 2005 he said
you know him and a couple of other guys
were just sitting around in the trailer
playing cards he said then suddenly he
felt the air he said it went like an
electrical kind of feel he's like you
know he's like that's kind of the best
way I can describe his dogs outside
going nuts again they were he said they
sounded really scared they were like
whining and yelping and stuff so he gets
up he goes out the window he doesn't see
anything and then he looks over the guy
who's playing cards with who looks kind
of like spaced out or confused or
whatever then he said he started hearing
like a buzzing sound
you know buzz and then another one and
then he said that the guy he'd been
playing cards with suddenly said we need
to go outside so they both go outside
and then they look up at the sky he said
at first he didn't see anything but then
he's like scanning through the sky and
after a couple seconds he said I saw a
spot in the sky that was somehow darker
than the sky I couldn't make out the
exact shape but I could tell something
was there that's the same thing you told
me about earlier yeah yeah well he saw
it's more than once okay um now he said
he looks over at the guy and he says he
was looking up into the sky like
as if he could see something up there
and he said I can hear it but he said I
didn't hear anything though and then he
said but this the guide like the look on
his face was like really freaked out
like he was in a trance or something
like that um then he said after a couple
of minutes that was really really bright
like flash and then the electrical
feeling like disappeared now he said the
creepiest thing about this was that
after that [ __ ] happened the other guy
said to him he said he said this really
creepy he's like I wish I could remember
what he said word for word he said I'm
paraphrasing but because it was like
really creepy what he said he said that
his friend said they talked to me and
that they said they knew what we were
doing here and that they were doing the
same thing only our roles were reversed
and then he said that they told him they
have the advantage and we can't stop
them from doing whatever they want okay
so that's what he said his friend said
so he said that was like he's like I
wouldn't have believed it either but he
said it was super creepy like the guy
seemed like he was really you know like
in a trance that he was like in he said
it was super creepy so what aliens came
here to send us a message that we got
you a suite we got you know we're
running the show pretty much so that's
the thing now this guy apparently said
you know I say I'd see another ship
before but he's like for some reason
that really like creeped me out I said
I'm not coming back here next time
around I won't work here anymore he's
like you know not only is there not much
going on but also you know I'm just
ending up being a ranch hand pretty much
but you know he's like that was kind of
creepy I don't want to do anymore so
that was like kind of all he said so
over the next few years like I said
different iterations of you know I think
mids kind of went out of business but
then they opened another one and then
there was another one and all this other
kind of [ __ ] so you know at this stage
who the [ __ ] knows what's going on out
there nobody really knows they made a
documentary about it in 2017 or 2018 and
I think there's even been like a
fictional movie made about it very
recently now before we wrap it up let's
talk about all the different phenomena
they just
reported by different people over the
years because this part of the website
just amused the hell out of me so here
like I said this is this was my favorite
part of the website because this is
where every single like phenomena every
single manifestation of things that have
been reported on skinwalker ranch
they've kind of broken it down into like
all of the different phenomenon this is
the meat and potatoes and then yeah yeah
and then they're saying like what your
percentage chance of seeing it is okay
like how common it is okay like I said
it's like it's a little graph and
everything alright alright so here's the
less crazy [ __ ] the first one is just
called the spotlight now this is a
single spotlight similar to that on
motorcycle travel is about 10 to 40
miles per hour
typically hovers about 8 feet from the
ground sometimes has a red tail light
behind it so it does kind of can fly
over any terrain tape to write terrain
type of bat yeah sounds kind of like a
dirt bike yeah yeah machine-like seems
to be able to read minds I'm not sure
why they think that but yes so usual
duration 10 seconds to 15 minutes 46
percent chance of seeing as a motorcycle
rider okay an expert rider
okay I must say that the area they're
talking about is wonderful dirt bike
territory yeah this is probably just
injure all right now maybe a four stroke
with a good motor on it from a distance
maybe you know especially if there's
music playing the background maybe you
wouldn't hear the most sound of the
motor yeah you know just saying it could
be just saying it could be I'd have to
see it myself
yeah most plausible explanation we're
talking about a motorcycle yeah yeah
rapping over things and jumping it not
even fun yeah and Tom's already imagine
it exact yeah the next thing is called
what are known as a flash drones okay
these are pulsating spherical balls of
light the light appears bluish to
yellow-green light it cast is not
extremely bright but it will cast light
on objects immediately surrounding the
orb to
quickly there's more than one word
gathered they have the ability to hover
make no noise that seems to be a pretty
common aspect of all of these things now
that all sounds fine and dandy but then
comes this sentence okay
have been seen transforming into other
animal shapes and is suspected of having
the ability to morph into the shape of
local living animal okay Tom bought
Native American stories here with what
you're dealing with
yeah spirit beings and like I said it
sounded plausible until that part yeah
they are we might be conflating two
things yeah maybe they saw some orbs in
the sky maybe he's talking about small
drones okay and then somebody says oh
you know what and they changed into
animals yeah how much fire water you
been drinking
well yeah because you saw a light in
this guy and they saw coyotes yeah yeah
I would I wouldn't read into it that
much okay and show me at the drone you
make off yeah I might say yeah cats a
coatl god damn it I mean especially if
you're interviewing me yeah
[Laughter]
lights cancer coatl Kukulcan yeah yeah
and if you have an investigator that I
guess might you know Google coincided
yes along with the feathered serpent you
know yeah sure so apparently the flash
drugs says these are unique in that they
appear almost curious about any humans
they come across they tend to take on a
more interactive role if the observer is
alone so there's that twenty if that's
real they've talked about drop what year
was this this is just over the course of
the good just thing various things had
been reported yeah they're just they're
breaking down all the different
phenomena that were dazed what some of
these small commercial drones I mean
Jenny now I'm thinking by buying a drone
yeah so we can do our our reviews of the
movies at the theater with
because we could walk around inside the
theater with the drone following us
shooting the footage I mean you know
these things are amazing and back in the
90s they had some cool stuff too
and a lot of people were they weren't
familiar with it yeah little
remote-control drones and you could put
LED lights on them or lights and you
know the person who wasn't familiar with
it would think that they're maybe we're
seeing something paranormal you know but
because they've been out for a long time
now there's no custom ones that guys
were building and it was rumored I
thought this guy what was his name again
I thought that he was making drones yeah
Bigelow I thought Bigelow made drones
for the government prototype stuff you
know well yeah if you heard that like I
said it's probably that's what I think
that's what he was involved in that I
think there's a contractor yeah but
don't hold me to that but that kind of
checks out that might have been a drunk
drone testing area yeah and you know
these might have been exotic prototype
drones not only could you fly a remote
control control them through cellular
waves you could also see through them
maybe they had VR helmets you know the
guys are controlling them and finding on
buzzing people you know back in the 90s
that wouldn't have been impossible it
just would have been very classified
yeah you can do that now easy yeah you
can buy the technology to do that now
yeah yeah so the next thing is called
the invisible chopper which is pretty
much should just what it sounds like you
basically are walking around in the
field whatever you hear something that
sounds like a helicopter going right
over your head just one time the other
ones but you don't see ya a big
quadcopter you know but you don't see
anything yeah cuz it's it's blacked out
yeah yeah
during the daytime no they are talking
about during your time during the
daytime and sometimes this is also
related to the controllers like I was
talking about earlier yeah like the
voices coming out of thin air
you also got your mini stealth which
again just as it sounds is a little
bitty craft about eight feet by six feet
that looks like a miniature stealth
fighter yeah these yeah these have been
seen several times just starting to make
sense now yeah yeah yeah now the next
one
bulletproof Wolf's bulletproof well
that's a we were talking about proof war
mists
your target I understand it you not I
mean it now I don't have good firearm
skills and your [ __ ] spooked and you
got a lot of adrenaline running to you
you're not sometimes you're not sure how
many rounds you fired off you're not
sure whether you hit or not you're doing
a lot of missing and you know the animal
ran off carried the bullet off with it
or just you know pops you know small but
flesh wound
now stop it so according to this website
however it says the bulletproof wolf has
an unusually long a bushy tail may
travel within the flash drones and
manifest from them as seen by two
researchers who requested this [ __ ]
unsubscribe yes then you then you got
your controllers which I talked about
earlier this is basically two male
voices speaking and something that
sounds like Russian or a choppy Native
American type language and the voices
coming out of thin air sounds like it's
going through a mechanical medium such
as radio like a CV or something like
that generally we'll stop talking if
they are acknowledged now we're getting
some more weirder ones to theirs here's
the thing called the dark one which
whoever wrote this website seems to
think it's some kind of ghost of a
shaman or something like that said it's
very very rare to see this like 0.03% or
something like that he's described as
male always being alone appears to be a
primitive native-american possibly Aztec
in origin he does not speak appears to
be residing outside of our known
timeline and even appears surprised at
times so yeah there is also because you
see a ghost or something like that in
this zone doesn't mean that these
phenomena are all related yes let's just
say you do see a ghost it may not have
anything to do with those drones those
UFOs yeah I mean if you the place are
talking about it's pretty big
you know it's hundreds of acres yeah you
got people living and some people that
have reported seeing UFO [ __ ] have been
like 10 miles away right on neighboring
properties it's not just statistically
yeah I think okay now some people have
also said that they heard like another
disembodied voice that sounded like a
little girl or an adolescent girl which
is also considered some type of ghost
phenomenon actually we didn't mention it
before but they were
some other type altar guys type
phenomena right that you said they
talked about on the documentary where
like a hairbrush would vanish and like
it would turn up in a weird place like
in the freezer in the freezer so there
is like some kind of minor ghost or
paranormal actor yeah but that means
that kind of stuff I'm not gonna say
that that's not happening I'm gonna say
that that's not related to the yeah
because the area they're talking about
is big enough to where you would
statistically have more than one
phenomenon in it yeah you know maybe
yeah and and what they're reporting is
it's kind of flimsy yeah yeah I'm
talking about I mean it might be miss
identification sand can you know might
be I think it's one of the Constitution
where the area is kind of known for
phenomenon so everyone is looking for
phenomenon look for phenomenon you're
gonna find something eventually yeah and
you know it's gonna be it's not gonna be
accurate now here's some more [ __ ]
that's going back to kind of Native
American legends from the area a pair
and apparently some people have reported
seeing this type of phenomena of these
things called water babies or power
picks which are supposedly these kind of
like I don't know if they're like demons
or creatures in like that but they sound
like a crying baby people go and
investigate and then they get sucked
into the water and drown now they said
that some people have actually drowned
in a nearby reservoir and that water
babies these water babies might be
responsible or that this next creature
called the Cthulhu slug is also
responsible what well water baby is a
Native American version of a kapa yeah
that's what it is ala man yeah and the
cop is a giant salamander if they're
Danner's actually you can kill a child
yeah grab a hold of your hand child's
hand and corn ate the water and drown
child's probably happened well yeah
they're big enough yeah they're big
enough they're bigger than it's more
scary large I didn't even like I never
realized that they actually existed
until I saw like some video of what
instead protected animal so you also got
your Cthulhu slug like I said this is
like a slug like or snake-like creature
that's supposedly like I said drags
swimmers into the nearby bottle hollow
reservoir now this website speculates
that it might be an interdimensional
type Lovecraftian type creature but you
know how that whole thing goes also got
your glow birds now this is something
that the Sherman's also reported that
they saw it like these exotic or
multicolored birds that didn't seem to
be native to the area some other people
have awesome well some people have also
reported these other birds that are like
red or there seem to be glowing or they
you know are just like glowing things
from far away always witness from a
distance got your orange football that's
another UFO like shape it's not metallic
but it's about 15 feet wide ten feet
tall and it's football shape usually
seen as an orange glowing ball of plasma
also got your sentient mist which
Bigelow and his researchers have
described as a neurological electricity
that's a direct quote completely black
in color takes the intangible form of a
thick smoke this is kind of like the
blue haze that you saw the other thing
smoke is described like a disembodied
skin of black electrified energy that
possesses an intellect so I don't know
what the hell that's all about and then
later on I love this part too under the
sentient mist section I was like
somebody saw the Stephen King movie the
mist because it says update so I guess
somebody new has described a new thing a
new aspect of this sentient mist
phenomenon update described as having
tentacles which it uses to toxify its
victims by inserting by the mouth and
thereby suffocating the lungs with what
feels like burning does so like where
they getting this did Sony report this
yes so they added it to the website hope
none all right yeah
resulting final form is believed to be a
lifeless yet physically real creature
usually seen for 30 seconds 2% chance of
seeing the sentient mist with or without
tentacles I don't know and the last
thing that was on the website is the
very famous portal and this is what the
schurmans reported said it looked like
an orange thing now some other people
have described it like oh we saw the
orange thing and then we saw the blue
thing
and I'm like wasn't that a video game
though like with the portal with the
orange and the blue that was video game
right somebody sounds baby I remember
and yeah well I think that's what that
might be but apparently because I think
the Sherman's described is like an
orange spirally looking thing and like
these little ships like came out of it
and like flew around like it was kind of
[ __ ] survey in the ground or some
[ __ ] like that so this is supposedly an
interdimensional portal that [ __ ] comes
out of and this is usually seen about
500,000 feet in this guy you know over
like near the ranch and so there's that
whole thing I love that says
manipulation of time-space are unique
energies to create a doorway to an
unknown location or reality usually seen
for 10 seconds 2% chance of seeing so
you have as much chance of seeing that
as you do the sentient miss with the
tentacles so okay you got that going for
you so what do you think of this case I
don't know man like so much I'm not
saying that maybe this particular piece
of land cuz I'm skeptical of UFO [ __ ]
mostly like I'm not saying that there
aren't extraterrestrials maybe there are
I don't know why they would come here
why they would bother but probably some
people have seen them if they do come
here that's not totally crazy but this
place it's just it seems like so much
crazy [ __ ] is going on and honestly it
seems like most of the real crazy [ __ ]
like bulletproof wolf and all that kind
of stuff kind of that stems from the
time that the shirt the quote-unquote
Sherman family were there so I'm not
sure how seriously I can take it because
yes Pete other people have seen UFOs
before they moved in there yes other
people have reported you know cryptid
type phenomena like before that but
there were also Native American legends
about the place purportedly you know
there's been UFO sightings there so I I
kind of feel like maybe the seeds of
something were there but then it kind of
somebody took it and kind of ran with it
and came up with like crazy stories
about but Erised dogs yeah and whatnot
not [ __ ] on anybody I'm just saying
it sounds wildly implausible yeah my
dear
yeah there's a big tract of land out
there
all right it's desert okay basically
which means you have really good
visibility at night it's near Air Force
bases yeah yeah so you have a high
probability of seeing aircraft at night
yeah and possibly an experimental
aircraft at night which leads to some
UFO reports yep okay and then you have
wacky families moving into that area
yeah who report even more wackier things
it's a large area later on a billionaire
who wants to work for the government
make drones flies that land okay to put
up a research facility there to maybe
build drones and you know build things
for the government and test them there
so it's like his own version of like s 1
or s 4 you know it's a near group lake
and while he's there he needs kind of
like a cover story or some kind of
camouflage so he does is he makes kind
of like a pair of normal Institute okay
to cloud the purpose of the whole
[ __ ] thing to make it seem kind of
hokey yeah okay that sounds a lot more
likely yeah I think that's probably what
it was is that he's building stuff there
as a cover story in a camouflage it's
this it's this hokey looking for
werewolves and investigating UFOs cover
story yeah all right because everyone
would talk about it and they would say
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] and then no
one would no one would give a [ __ ]
totally be a supervillain
it's called dissing from disinfo or miss
info you know it's a it's just it's a
cover story that's right sounds a lot
more likely yeah it sounds a little more
likely didn't bulletproof was an
interview well the bulletproof wolves
was a story made up by somebody that
actually lived there and that actually
kind of helped to kind of dissuade
people from looking at this kind of
that's all [ __ ] yeah but now they're
probably building drones there or
something or something like that yeah
not nefarious is some kind of something
for the Air Force imagination small
stealth craft there yeah all right well
that's what a drone is well yeah they
have one that looks like a little stuff
lean I forgot what it's called and
that's it one of the old ones yeah it's
kind of DeltaWing with a jet in a jet
engine in it
unmanned just pretty small you know and
it's just got cameras and you can fly it
around fly around look at stuff and
shoot off shoot off Hellfire missiles
[ __ ] like that out of it that's what
that's what sad that s'what they're
talking about I think Oh probably 99.99%
of the time when people see UFOs are
hear about UFOs stories that's probably
what it is it's probably like some [ __ ]
going on that's like supposed to be
secret and then they're just like no man
it's like aliens and then everybody's
like yeah whatever it's like it's big
lows copying what they did with what's
the name of the one the big famous one
right outside of crinum like there
what's a quiet area 51 area 51 what came
in that case Roswell rats yeah they did
find something out there and they did
print a newspaper back then that the
military found a flying saucer or the
reports you know the remains of a flying
saucer but it was a misidentification I
think was a misprint there what they
really found was a secret balloon from
there and from that time forward they
used that UFO story to camouflage what
was really happening and now yeah that
the skunk works they're building yes
sr-71 it's what they were built well it
seems like a smart thing to do yeah
because people would people it's like a
it's like a huge distraction yeah
instead of worrying about the sr-71
they're worried about a flying saucer
and anyway his lime sauce because if it
was an alien flying sauce it that would
be a lot me yeah you can't you couldn't
hide that military installation so you
have to have another technique to shroud
it you're like hi
yeah so you can't hide it so what you do
is you shroud it you know in into a into
an a fantastic story yeah okay to keep
you from it's like it's like a
sleight-of-hand trick to keep you from
looking at the damn sr-71 yeah because
they're really worried like you search
that then it's gonna be like all these
crazy conspiracy theory like YouTube
videos although I think yes I think the
71 was only one of the things that they
were working on and and you know it was
a balloon it was a balloon that could
sense detonations of nuclear bombs over
in Russia project mogul yeah it was a
mogul balloon and they didn't want it
they didn't want to mention mogul yeah
okay it was classified so I think D I
think the Army Air Forces go with the
UFO story yeah let that run and then
we'll come on say no it was just a
weather balloon yeah I think that was
part of the deception I think it started
off as an accident than they went let's
roll with it well because if you say oh
it was just a weather balloon then all
the people who wanted it to be UFO it to
be like oh it's a conspiracy it really
was a UFO and then they'll run with it
in the other direction and then you know
then they'll be like hehehe nobody
thinks it's UFOs yeah now they don't
know anything about project mogul you
can't get him to believe in project
mogul and they would never know anything
about what they were working on the
sr-71 at that time very beginnings oh
it's ingenious
yeah probably do the same thing you see
they go out there and build drones yeah
and where do [ __ ] doesn't want anybody
know that he's out there building
drawings so instead he's he's out there
looking for UFOs yeah yeah and you guys
since the werewolves and others talked
about that yeah which just like we're
doing right now all right so you
probably is that your second Kukulcan or
just your uh it's like one and a half
okay so topped off so before you fall
over out of your chair before you get
too far out into the stratosphere we're
gonna wrap up this
125 about skinwalker ranch you know it
was fun show though to do it was like a
fun show to research too because that's
just yeah you know I'm not positive that
I'm not even positive that that guy was
working on drones
I just seemed to remember that he's
working on drones from my sources yeah I
don't know I had to go look at it again
he was working on something for the
government yeah he's a contractor yeah I
think it was drones
but yeah so anyway hope you guys enjoyed
our rambling as usual discussion and
that'll do it for episode 125 remember
if you liked the show to like share
subscribe and all your social media
share with all your friends and family
and everywhere else if you'd like to
financially support show you can go to
our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
also remember to check out our zazzle
stores Apple comm / 13 o'clock we've got
like t-shirts and mason jars and all
kind of fun [ __ ] I'm gonna add some more
stuff over the upcoming months whenever
I have time to do some new t-shirt
designs I've got a couple requests I got
to work on
also remember to go check out my new
audio book baseless villain vol 2 which
now add an audio and if you don't have a
cell phone like crazy if you don't have
an audible account and you want me to
get a bounty like on the one that you
buy then go there will be a link in the
description that you see on - for
audiobooks [ __ ] drop four faces bill
in part two it's it's one of the best
rated new audiobooks yeah and when you
look at the new sections yeah so
everybody think everybody loves writing
for writing good reviews yeah if you buy
it and liked it please press more it
really does help a lot and I think that
will do it for this episode and that'll
do it for episode hundred twenty five so
we will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]